Okay, so
let's revisit this idea of isolation.
When it comes to protection and
security, isolation is
actually your best friend.
Okay, that means that I'm
isolated from somebody else and
they can't do anything bad to me.
Untrusted user code has to be
isolated from the system code, okay.
We talked about trusted system code
tamper-proofness that we're talking.
You shouldn't be able to alter it and
the only way you can go in to operating
system is through system calls
that are defined by
the operating system and so on.
So how are we going to achieve
this isolation of user code?
The reason I wanted to think about
this is what does a processor do?
It says fetch the next instruction.
To execute it you need some operands
that are somewhere in memory.
You fetch those you execute
the instruction and
you keep doing that forever.
But I'm using let's say running
executing some user code.
Why can't I say the next
instruction I want to switch to
somewhere in the operating system or
the next data item I want to bring
is a data structure that resided
in the operating system?
If you tried to do that we said
you wouldn't be able to do it.
Because we have this execution
mode we're talking about,
and things like that.
So, we're going to use that
hardware support to achieve or
accomplish this isolation,
separating, or separation,
of user code from
the operating system code.
So let's see how we actually
going to be able to do that.
Well the way to do that is again I said.
It's going to rely on
the hardware to protect memory.
So remember isolation I said the way.
Executing in user mode or
executing user code and at
that point if the hardware can protect
memory where the operating system is.
What does memory protection mean.
We said the process in which read
write request or load store request or
execute those instructions to
fetch the next instruction or
fetch the data that it's
going to operate on.
It's going to generate an address
where it wants to do a read or write.
Well, the hardware says,
you're not allowed to access
that part of the memory.
Okay, hardware support is saying,
it is part of memory that
belongs to the operating system.
Okay, that's what the operating
system code and data is.
If you're running in user mode, you are
not allowed to generate an address and
complete a read write in
a memory location that
belongs to the operating system.
So hardware support memory
protection essentially says,
if the process happens to generate an
address that is in the operating system,
the hardware support we have for
memory protection is going to stop
that memory access from completing.
Although it's generating an address, and
it's a memory location, the hardware
that potentially can do a read or
write there but
it currently knows that it's user code.
And user code directly can't access
the information that we have
in the operating system part.
So the hardware is going to essentially
stop that access from proceeding.
So hardware is going to sort of
keep you contained in your space.
And we get to that,
it's not just OS user, but
it's also across different
user processes, but
it's going to contain you within
the area of memory that belongs to you.
And if you try to touch something else.
Which you can.
It's going to stop you from doing that.
And the hardware is going to do that.
All this hardware support we have for
memory protection is
actually going to do that.